[موسيقى]
نرصد لكم على هذا الطريق الواصل بين ريف
حلب الشرقي ومدينه جنديرس الغربيه حلب
وصول عشرات الشاحنات المقدمه من العشائر
في دير الزور وذلك ضمن مبادره محليه تاتي
ضمن التكافل الاجتماعي لسد حاجه الاهالي
هنا في المنطقه جراء الزلزال وتاتي هذه
المبادره بعد النقص في تقديم المساعدات من
قبل الامم المتحده وهذه السيارات مستمره
بالوصول عبر هذا الطريق الواصل الى جنديرس
وتعتبر مدينه جنديرس من هي اكثر المناطق
تضررا هنا جراء الزلزال وتدمر فيها اكثر
من 85 بالمئه وايضا فيها الاف العائلات هي
تشردت جراء هذا الزلزال وايضا هي بحاجه
الى تقديم الاغذيه والايواء كما تحدث لنا
مسؤولين في هذه القافله تحتوي على خيام
لكن يبقى حاجه المنطقه هي حاجه اكبر من
هذه المساعدات وهي بحاجه الى مساهمه دول
لسد حاجه المتضررين جراء هذا الزلزال
عمر الحوراني الجزيره
من منطقه جنديرس في حلب الشمالي سوريا